there's a new effort in Congress to help
families of America's fallen
servicemembers get the benefits they say
they deserve the problem is called the
widows tax and this Memorial Day it's
been thrust back into the spotlight at
O'Keefe is on Capitol Hill
good morning what is the widow's tax
well good morning Tony a good question
and blacks roughly 65,000 military
widows from receiving full benefits from
the Pentagon and the department's of
Veterans Affairs and now some of those
widows are spending time up here on
Capitol Hill reminding lawmakers that
helping the families of the Fallen
should be a top priority he wanted to
make the world a better place so that
his sons would have a better life when
Tracey fol Keys husband Army Major paul
volcker was killed in action seven years
ago she not only had to deal with losing
her spouse she also had to worry about
her family's financial future there's
are an archaic rule on the books that if
you get money from the VA that money
offsets any money that's paid by the DoD
a widow can get roughly thirteen hundred
dollars a month tax-free from a
compensation fund run by the VA if they
agree not to hold the government
responsible for their spouses death some
also get a payment from a Defense
Department survivors benefit plan that
their deceased spouse had paid into but
the 1972 law that launched the Pentagon
program blocks some of these families
from collecting from both funds instead
for every dollar a spouse gets from the
VA they lose a dollar of survivor
benefits from the Pentagon it's known as
the widow's tax Tracy said she's missed
out on $1,300 every month for seven
years that's more than one hundred
thousand dollars I think part of the
reason why my husband served was he knew
that if something were to happen we'd be
taken care of now Democratic senator
Doug Jones of Alabama and Republican
Susan Collins of Maine are leading a
bipartisan campaign to fix the problem
more than 70 senators support the plan
hundreds of members in the house back a
similar idea this is a case of
tremendous unfair
we have an obligation not only to the
service members but to their families
people have talked to us and they've
expressed that anger and they're right
they should be angry hey Kathy Milford
lost her husband more than 25 years ago
has been dealing with the widows tax
ever since I mean it's been pretty
amazing the way this is going three
years ago she decided it was time to
start lobbying Congress it's very
difficult for me because I have to keep
telling about my husband died my husband
died my husband died and that's I would
rather talk about our life together
rather than talking about his death
after so many years the current fight to
fix the problem might finally be paying
off
I'm hoping this Memorial Day that people
call their congressmen and the people at
the DoD can kind of listen to our
stories and see that we're not just a
bill this isn't just a bill that you
have to pay this is a cost of war and
this is what our families are owed now
the Pentagon tells us that this would
cost roughly six billion dollars to fix
that's a big cost but with Congress
already trying to sort out some tax
issues for benefits given to the
children of servicemembers there's a
hope that Congress will also address the
issue for widows which is lingered for
far longer Anthony all right ed thanks I
can't think of anybody more deserving of
those six billion dollars on those
widows you know and the bills are
written they're lined up they just
haven't gone through because people are
larding them up with other issues if
it's a clean bill it will pass and has
the support we heard you do wonder who's
opposed but he said to call your
congressperson please don't do it today
because they're not there but call them
tomorrow home tomorrow and make it clear
that you disagree if you do